there's a massive criminal network
there's anything huge amounts of people
now he's very dangerous so many people
had been through horror there is the
fence now it's just absolutely crazy
dangerous
[Music]
it's very easy to focus a lot of
attention on the drug cartels and the
crime syndicates that run not just
Mexico but all of South and Central
America what we wanted to see was the
actual movement of the people themselves
it is quite a humanitarian crisis so
these people running away from their own
countries because they don't have money
or the gangs threaten them the people
smuggling is absolutely out of control
unregulated business worth millions
they'll smuggle anything whether it be
guns drugs or migrants or they'll do a
mall at the same time we wanted to be
with migrants as they were making their
journey through Mexico and up into the
United States many of those people have
to come through Guatemala so we needed
to start our trip in Guatemala but we
also needed to get to the crime gangs
who move drugs and people in exactly the
same way
[Music]
gana mana is a sort of entry point to
Mexico
it's especially very dangerous as
against on the border where the crime
gangs aren't really really violent
no matter how confident you feel the
local people you work with there's
always this nagging doubt that you are
going into the unknown you are dealing
with some pretty dangerous people
they are cartel your kind of safety
really is in in the hands of the
guidance so they know they've got to get
to a location of little beat on them
okay let's not tempt fate
we knew other cartels were operating
down there and we definitely didn't want
to attract their attention because these
are not only people smuggling routes but
they're also drug smuggling routes we
arrived to predetermined location
[Music]
within minutes a sort of slightly
bedraggled group of people walked out of
the mist and the darkness
[Music]
what struck me straightaway there's some
really young girls are not green it's
the beginning of the journey for these
people they're going what thousands of
miles Muslim to try to get to the United
States so they have to use the
traffickers who will get them there but
it's going to cost them money open you
know so pero you've almost uh are you
guys are you there mr. asperities but
que hace mucho para second dose Atlanta
yo and also just to make it a messiah
and we headed off into the hills on this
or turn out to be a pretty special
journey the system guarantees they get
to Mexico and much further on and in
fact for some of them they believe that
they're being smuggled all the way
through two cities in the United States
they're paying quite a lot of money to
what is called a coyote this is a person
who oversees the group is it safer for
everyone to travel together in a group
like this fall apart again others have
come back
porque si nos a reportin or Syria Han
Solo's in Julio de tolosa questrom
kilowatt improperly the root is a
completely illegal smuggling route it's
no danger from officialdom your danger
is always from gangs there is these two
young girls one of them is 16 and one of
them was 14 they knew they were on a
dangerous trip I just don't think they
realize how dangerous that trip it could
be the truth is for many girls they can
be raped and can be forced into sex
slavery and that's just heartbreaking it
really was it was their naivety I think
that's what was so worrying and
upsetting
[Music]
it was very touching actually really
poignant moment it was just a few
minutes before we crossed into Mexico
[Music]
I've got a little girl myself and it
just broke my heart just to think that
she was so full of hope and enthusiasm
for her future but at the same time I
knew what was likely to happen to her
well this has been quite a trip through
the mountains just around the corner
from here we're going to enter Mexico
you heard say goodbye to them really did
[Music]
they will then keep moving on and moving
on going from one set of gangsters to
another set of gangsters all the way up
to the American Board if you could
affect you just pick them up and put
them in the United States or giving them
enough money to go home you would you
can't
[Music]
if you've crossed over from Guatemala
you're going to go to Tampa tuna do you
have volleyball people on the move then
you almost guarantee that they'll be
preyed upon by crime gangs and with
crime gangs is usually the sex industry
you could see prostitutes on the street
and some of these girls were young I
mean they were really young that made
the team feel concerned to the welfare
of the young girls here eat just man
this girl we met she's now a
professional prostitute that's what she
does but she didn't start life like that
this girl had crossed the Guatemalan
border with a coyote she was effectively
sold and was never allowed out and
worked as a prostitute to pay the debt
for five months her debt was $100 it was
quite staggering rattling triples it was
be a lot of suppliers importer person
we're up where we left all stuff I think
the perhaps has to decide us be that
guilt that she felt she was responsible
for what happened to her and I think
anyone who's ever done stories on this
knows and it's such a standard thing
that happens for women have been abused
all over the world I know have you
survived
don't be totally honest Philippe Royal
Signals
in West LA siroque our Atlanta
sometimes she works on the streets and
sometimes she's in this brothel and that
unfortunately brought home to us what
the outcome of this journey is for many
of these young girls that got to
everybody I really did okay from now
there is a global network of gangs all
facilitating the passage of migrants
from wherever they come from in the
world through Central America and up
into the USA so like a cargo town except
the cargos are humans now we actually
found people from India Pakistan
Bangladesh certainly nothing we expected
to see in Mexico their tales and exactly
where they have come from are actually
mind-boggling to guys we spoke to in
particularly work from India told us how
they had been robbed and beaten all the
way along their journey day and the boys
talk very much about the ten-day walk
that they had to do through the jungles
in Panama
Afiya has a refund like gun sward they
kill if man not survive in the jungle if
you fell behind if you injured yourself
who you became ill they just shot you
dead and left you in the jungle so this
just sounds like the worst thing you
could ever have imagined on earth you
can see the dead bodies laying
we have smell of death for years the
most amazing thing for me is that they
think that they were lucky they said I'm
lucky because I still alive
[Music]
there are a number of crossing points
into the United States that are proper
big cross importance and one is Nogales
this literally been split down the
middle by the US border wall and so
we've got Nogales on the US side which
is an Arizona and then you've got
Nogales on the Mexican side we saw this
one family who were standing having a
conversation through this fence they're
physically unable to be together
our experience there was to try and meet
up with the gangs that would actually
facilitate the movement of people across
the u.s. border and we're on our way to
a meeting with one of the drug gangs
which also deals in people there are
Sinaloa cartel affiliated gang killing
of journalists in Mexico is very common
for the killing a foreign journalist is
very rare but you are dealing with gangs
where I'm greeted by a masked man with
an ak-47 in this hat and the guy with
the Kalashnikov never left outside and
they had his eyes on us the whole time
you can move marijuana you can move to
again but also you can move people as
well you live in what's tomorrow right
you'll send me people to here so you
call me let me know and it's crossing
very easy
nobody's okay right now he's very
dangerous you have to pay the Mafia to
grow the people to devastate clearly
this meeting had been about checking us
out as ultimately we wanted to get to
the border to see the people who were
being smuggled illegally although they
are a gang they're actually the safest
way to get across the border without
them you've got no protection whatsoever
one of the things of dealing with
criminals in my street either
I have up you something explained anyway
Kenya normally they keep their ward
the inner hub timetable there was as is
usual with these things a bit waiting
around it was on it was off it was only
it was off I started to have my doubts
actually about whether they were serious
or whether they changed their minds then
all of a sudden
Ulysses got the call
field for working if we want to see the
jump on my time very close to be gained
a full four hours and fall back in pitch
darkness I was quite worried about the
team so you know he's coming to get you
in the middle of the night in the middle
of a desert in a place that you're not
supposed to be with a load of cartel
members
it's been going on and off now for what
feels like forever I think we will
definitely have no choice but to go out
and see the gang we were meant to be
moving these miners I'll have to make a
decision on whether I think it's
possible to get to the border and
whether it's too dangerous to do it they
were very adamant that it had to be very
small groups are really 14 I have to go
where the other Caesars are translated
because something
the road will have meant to me the
smuggling gang and some of the people
who want to cross the border into the
United States that tonight will show how
much you'll be able to see or her father
again we drove out into the middle of
nowhere why do we spend all our time in
gone shitty roads going to meet dodgy
people
see them coming back this is the last
bit of the journey by car very shortly
we're going to be dropped off and we're
going to begin that
she faces this to the guys here at enemy
across the border into the United States
people with initials the way that will
obviously come back we were driven even
further out into the countryside to a
drop-off point
it takes some planning but is it quite
easy getting over we met coyote the guy
who was going to take one migrant across
and we met the migrant who looked very
nervous indeed it was costing him five
thousand US dollars a family had stumped
together to get the money and so the
start of a new life he wanted to go over
there and get some work and he could
change their lives their way of doing it
is to know which bit of the border has
not got Border Patrol and they use that
by having spotters
they were getting near the border now
it's what we've gone into a night shot
it's getting very dark out here and
they're very very jumpy they keep
checking saying people are coming people
have anyone around it's not so much
actually the authorities but more other
gangs because everyone use these routes
and they can't be very very dangerous as
a result of that because your start
fighting amongst themselves but they
very keen to keep going and suddenly we
come through this clearing and there it
is there's the border between the United
States and Mexico
Terry's Darius defense now
they're coming yeah this brother bit of
a Louisville heat sensors on the offense
which is just there which why the wonder
is going in the air but the guys have
disappeared in others other people we
think coming so we've gotta get out of
here the guys themselves were very
nervous and very jumpy they were not
hanging around
we've just walked back from the border
was actually scary and coming out that
was going in I will wait for car to come
pick us up we actually got to the border
the guys have got over well I think this
show that's just really with a bit of
organization how easy it is for people
to get across that border and something
that the United States government and
the messin up a little discussed often
the border is there you can't stop
people Carson
[Music]
Jim chilsen is an old-style
Rancho United States my range is just
the Porsche brand wide work cattle
things he has about 22 miles of fence
that is the border between Mexico the
United States
he's an 80 year old man and he showed us
surveillance video it clearly shows
large groups of cartel members drug
mules coming through his land every day
he is confronted by Mexican drug cartels
they are quite literally on Jim's door
stands and he's been putting up with
this for years we had a border patrolmen
almost killed our ranch
it's not the Wild West it is the Wild
West yeah and he took us on this big
long drive down to his land like a herd
of turtles
I mean you realized how fast his land is
is undoubtedly somebody up there
now the Mexican side order is being used
by hotel scouts so the scouts live up on
this mountain do you think it'll be
cartel members out there watching us now
they know where we are right now they're
watching us everybody out a wave to the
scouts direct the operations of the drug
cartel and the people being smuggled
over no I was just filming and I could
hear some voices only I knew the team
were over there but the voices were
coming from over there and on this
hilltop just over the Mexican side of
this faint it's not seeing some movement
with cartel Scouts you can see the money
you find out yeah you can see them
really clearly here
I couldn't believe it I was like I can
actually see them up there and then
Kraig got the drone up and tried to fill
their position I see you there we could
see them moving around quite clearly and
I had seen a long weapon which looked
like an okay so we knew that they were
armed probably telling us to go away you
know there were a few more shots and
then we started to hear voices
I suddenly spotted two of them walking
down the hill guys walking down this
path right now I'm coming down the hill
are two blokes from the hideout shouting
amigo yeah then I said well I'm gonna go
over and see if I can talk to them
over there on your own that is one of
those moments that could go either way
it could have gone very very badly
indeed I was wondering how dangerous are
these guys going to be it could be very
dangerous
but on the balance of probabilities
right gyms are trying he's a ranch it's
got missiles and rifles with it and it
was quite clear quite clearly that they
were actually shouting for something and
started talking ttyn in their balaclavas
on the other side say they were there
for sort of three months living on the
hill you work for the cartel
their job was to look down at what's
happening on Jim's farm while Jim is
standing next to us and many people come
through Larry
none of us really spoke any Spanish they
didn't really speak any English no
Sierra there we were standing on either
side of this little barbed-wire fence
having a chitchat doesn't happen every
day I mean this is sort of a crazy thing
that we're we're / a piece of barbed
wire yeah I know and some railway track
it was an interesting moment and a
really quite a poignant one that the two
two were there together you know which
one's the victim here yeah you just
don't know it's like it's Jim the victim
because they're coming across or related
fictions because they're so poor they
don't go near water and they're living
on a mountain it's very easy to cast
everyone involved in is pretty awful
trade is really really evil it's not
clear-cut as you would like to think
everybody along the line apart from a
fortunate few are all desperate and that
includes the drug smugglers and the
people smugglers they've all grown up in
these terrible place
and they're all making a living the best
way they know how all these people we
saw on this trip we're just trying to
make their lives better in some kind of
way I know that it's illegal they stole
that they are doing but they're just
escaping from violence and trying to
find a job and a decent way of life the
authorities have no way at this stage to
stop and people prepared to take a risk
that most of us would never even
consider
[Music]